[Musique]
Je vais te dire quelque chose,
j'ai formé les Gardiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amoureux,
cette fille est morte mais ensuite elle est revenue, elle est
revenue comme une [ __ ] totale oh s'il te plaît,
il a oublié des informations importantes
mais
c'est l'essentiel
[Musique]
ma mission sacrée
est de créer la société parfaite,
il ne voulait pas rendre les choses parfaites,
il détestait juste les choses telles qu'elles sont
[Musique]
Je veux que vous sachiez tous que je suis reconnaissant
de me battre aux côtés de mes amis pour
les incinérer
étranger
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à ce que nous nous trouvions,
êtes-vous prêt
pour One Last Ride,
nous nous envolerons tous ensemble
vers l'éternité
[Musique]
et un ciel magnifique
[Applaudissements]
peu importe celui dont vous étiez amoureux,
ça ressemble plus à elle, à elle  ne m'y amène pas, fais-le
tomber, ce qui
n'a jamais remarqué à quel point tes yeux étaient noirs,
ils ont été remplacés par mon père comme
méthode de torture, il a choisi un joli
ensemble